Forgive me if you're feeling upset or
bored. I don't choose
right
to speak in a manner where I have a
prepared speech or outline. I have a
topic. I go live ask Holy Spirit to take
over. So I hope you're blessed.
All right? So be wise as snakes,
harmless as doves. You are not going to
defeat this ideology. It's not going to
happen.
It's not going to happen, man.
Yes, Christian Zionists are
dieh hard supporters of Israel because
they think that Israel is for fulfilling
part prophecy leading to the return of
Jesus Christ and others because they
hate Islam so much. They hate it so much
that they'll now go to the opposite
extreme. Whereas Christians are called
to be balanced.
You are zealous, extreme gungle for the
Lord Jesus Christ and his rule. So you
speak the truth, stand up for its right.
Whether in this case Israel's right,
then you speak the truth and take their
side. If the Palestinians are right, you
speak the truth because your allegiance
is to the Lord Jesus Christ. It has to
be.
Let me remind you what the Christian
Zionists are preparing the Jews for. Let
me remind you again. You ready? One more
time. Let's begin. It's all about
Muhammad. Anyway,
this is what Christian Zionism
believes.
It believes that once the Jews are in
the land, right before the Lord Jesus
Christ returns,
are you listening? Rumble mga
you're listening
do you know that part of the theology of
Christian Zionism
whether they admit it or not whether
they realize it or not is that once the
Jews have returned to the land twothirds
of them
so hey Israelis
Nanyahu do you know evangelical theology
ology
thinks that once you enter the land,
twothirds of you will be wiped out,
destroyed, murdered. Twothirds of you.
Where am I getting this from? Zechariah
13. This is part of the theology of
Christian Zionism.
So when the evangelicals
are supporting what they call aliyah
going up to Israel and trying to get as
many Jews back in the land what they may
not be aware because they don't know
their theology
and those who do are not telling you
according to Zechariah 12:13-14
in order
for the Lord to descend on Mount Olives
and then rule from Jerusalem first there
has to be the slaughter of the Jews. The
nations come up against the Jews and
twothirds of them will
twothirds.
This is what Christian Zionism believes.
Did you know that? Here it is. Zechariah
13:7 tonight.
Yeah, Mimi. In fact, I want to find you
a clip that chunky yogurt played where a
liberal democratic Jew
spilled the beans and says,
"Evangelicals are not your friends.
Evangelicals are not your friends. They
want you to go to land because they're
expecting twothirds of the Jews to be
murdered for their Jesus to return."
Here it is.
Zechariah 13:7-9.
Maraga, you got it.
Awake, O sword, against my shepherd and
against the man my associate declares
Yahweh host. Strike the shepherd that
the sheep may be scattered and I will
turn my hand against the little ones and
it will be in the land. Now watch how
many will be killed.
It will be in all the land, declares
Yahweh, that two parts in it will be cut
off. Two parts and breathe their last.
Those in the land, twothirds will be
killed. So 9 million Jews, six million
will be killed, but the third will be
left in it. See it?
See it?
I don't answer emails, brother. Don't
send me an email.
Show them them. Say, "Hey, Christian
Zionist, do you believe this? You're
you're waiting for Jesus return at the
cost of twothirds of the Jews being
murdered, slaughtered,
but the third will be left in it. Only a
third. So if there's 9 million, only 3
million, 6 million got to go.
And I'll bring the third part through
the fire and refine them as silver is
refined and test them as gold is tested.
They will call on my name and I will
answer them. I will say they are my
people and they will say Yahweh is my
God.
You see it.
What about Zechariah 2? That got nothing
to do with what I just said. Daniel, are
you listening or are you pretending to
listen? Because according to the New
Testament, when Jesus came to earthly
Jerusalem, they rejected him. He rejects
earthly Jerusalem. And you know what?
He's going to bring down heavenly
Jerusalem to the earth. Daniel, do you
know your Bible? Go read Revelation
197-9. Revelation 21. It says Jesus will
now bring heavenly Jerusalem to the
earth, replacing earthly Jerusalem. Are
you a New Testament Christian or Old
Testament do you want to be?
Galatians 4 21-26 says earthly Jerusalem
is Hagar
and the heavenly Jerusalem is our mother
and she is Sarah. Hebrews 12:22-24 says
heavenly Jerusalem is our home and
Revelation 21 says heavenly Jerusalem
will come down to the earth.
Keep sticking with the Old Testament and
grow nor the New Testament. See they
that's all they have is Old Testament.
They never go to New Testament to allow
Jesus to explain the Old Testament. Do
you guys know that, right? The only
thing they can point to is Romans 11.
And that they butcher and doesn't
support their case. But every passage
they quote is Old Testament. They can't
show you from the New Testament.
Why is that?
I did millions of sessions on it. But
let me show you now. Zechariah 13:8,
two parts. What does two parts mean? And
I'm going to show you the message of the
New Testament is when Jesus came to
earthly Jerusalem and they rejected him,
he then rejected Jerusalem
and he's now going to bring heavenly
Jerusalem to the earth. That's New
Testament. Let me show it to you one
more time. Can we do it one more time?
Go watch the series I did. I give you
receipts, but I'm going to show it to
you again. Now, can you see the screen,
guys? Is it large enough?
How many Jews will be slaughtered
according to the understanding of
Christian Zionism? Twothirds.
Two parts right here.
Twothirds shall be cut off and perish.
See it? Twothirds.
Here, let me just put thirds.
See it?
Zechariah 13:8.
Now, I'm going to show you what Jesus
thinks of earthly Jerusalem. Ready? All
right.
You ready?
Watch here.
And I'm going to tell you what Jerusalem
is true and what Jerusalem
will the Lord Jesus reign in. Okay. And
then we're going to go into the topic.
Yeah.
Right here.
You guys know you're New Testament or
you still Old Testament Jews?
Okay. Matthew 23:37-39.
Jerusalem, Jerusalem, who kills the
prophets and stones those who are sent
to her. How often I wanted to gather
your children together. The way ahead
gathers her chicks under her wings, and
you did not want it. Behold, your house
is being left to you desolate. Wait, is
that in your Bible, you Christian
Zionist? Your house is left desolate,
abandoned. And then Matthew 24 describes
how Jerusalem will be destroyed with the
temple. For I say to you from now on,
you will not see me until you say,
"Blessed is he who comes in the name of
the Lord."
Now look what he calls Jerusalem.
Earthly Jerusalem. Ready? Look what he
calls earthly Jerusalem. Revelation
11:8. Hey Christian Zionists, this is
what our God, your God says about
earthly Jerusalem.
and their dead bodies will lie in the
street of the great city which
spiritually is called Sodom and Egypt
where also their Lord was crucified.
Can I ask you a question? Where was the
Lord Jesus crucified?
Jerusalem.
What did Jesus call Jerusalem? Sodom and
Egypt.
Orthodox Jews say that the modern state
of Israel is not of God. They say
Moshiach will come and restore the land.
You're still not convinced? All right.
What Jerusalem is true? Look, Galatians
4:21-26. Tell me, you who want to be
under law, do you not listen to the law?
For is written that Abraham had two
sons, one by the servant woman, one by
the free woman, but the son by the
servant woman had been born according to
the flesh, while the son by the free
woman through the promise. This is
spoken with allegory. For these women
are two covenants. Listen, Daniel,
David, whoever was. One from Mount Si
bearing children to slavery. Mount Si is
Hagar,
not the wife, the slave woman who gave
birth to slaves.
Mount Sai is Hagar and Hagar is what?
Mount Sai is what? Now, this Hagar is
Mount Sai in Arabia and corresponds to
the present Jerusalem. For Jerusalem is
in slavery with your children. Are you
sure you're a New Testament
Christian?
He just told you your Jerusalem that you
are salivating over the Jerusalem on
earth where apostate prophet went and he
started you know getting emotional
you know he got super emotional and
wailing wall and he got excited. Paul a
Jew of Jews says this Jerusalem is
Hagar.
Then which Jerusalem is the true
Jerusalem? But the Jerusalem above is
free and she is our mother. Do I need to
keep repeating these passages? How many
times do I need to repeat these
passages? Guys, this is the 10 millionth
time I've showed you these passages. Why
do you guys forget?
If you forget, how you going to use
them? All right.
Which Jerusalem? The one above. Here it
is. Hebrews 12:22-24. But you have come
to Mount Zion, where to the city of
living God, the heavenly Jerusalem,
and to myriads of angels, to the
festival gathering, assembly of the
firstborn, who are enrolled in heaven,
and to God the judge of all, and to the
spirits of the righteous made perfect,
and to Jesus, the meteor of a new
covenant, and to the sprinkled blood,
which speaks better than the blood of
Abel.
All right. What's going to come down to
the earth when Jesus comes? heavenly
Jerusalem. Revelation 21:104.
Then I saw a new heaven, new earth, for
the first heaven, first earth passed
away, and there's no longer any sea. And
I saw the holy city, new Jerusalem,
coming down out of heaven from God.
So what Jerusalem is Jesus going to
reign in? Heavenly Jerusalem. What
Jerusalem will be on earth? Heavenly
Jerusalem. Because when he came to
earthly Jerusalem, they rejected him.
And he rejected earthly Jerusalem,
calling it Hagar, calling it Sodom and
Egypt.